♪♪
-Hey, everybody, welcome
once again to "Corrections,"
and we're going
to get right into it.
We did a joke about
how Big Bird
got the COVID vaccine,
and the punch line
was he's now the quarterback
for the Green Bay Packers,
and we then showed
a graphic of Big Bird
wearing a football helmet.
Football helmets are for safety.
That is the role they play.
And some of you
correctly pointed out
it would not be that safe
if the bar was between the top
and bottom of your beak.
I called Big Bird a Muppet,
and some people said
he's not a Muppet,
but I'm going to die
on that hill.
I think he's a Muppet.
Prove I'm wrong.
We had another joke about
how Oscar the Grouch
got the Hep C vaccine.
And I was told that
while there is a vaccine
for hepatitis A and B,
there is not, to this point,
a hepatitis C vaccine.
They have been trying
to develop one,
but I guess
they can't figure out
how to get
the tracking chip to work.
[ Laughter ]
And so the FDA won't approve it
because they're like,
"If we can't track the people
who get it, what's the point?"
I try very hard not to
name-drop during "Corrections."
And this is not a correction.
This is just a celebrity story.
I met Big Bird.
Caroll Spinney,
the original Big Bird.
Rest in peace.
Caroll Spinney came to SNL.
Did an Update features
with Caroll Spinney
and the most fascinating part
about the whole thing
was how Caroll Spinney
reads his lines,
because he can't see
the cue cards
because he's in
a giant bird costume.
And he had a pen light
that he held in his mouth
and like a tiny clipboard
where he was reading it.
And at one point, live,
I heard the clipboard drop.
[ Laughter ]
And later, Erik Kenward,
who's a writer
and producer at "SNL,"
said that watching
the whole thing was like
watching someone operate
a Civil War submarine.
[ Laughter ]
This one, sometimes
this happens on the show.
I said Necco Wafers,
people told me Necco Wafers
were discontinued,
I corrected myself,
and then a slew of people
said Necco Wafers
were discontinued
for two years
and then a different company
bought Necco
and is now -- you can get
Necco Wafers.
I also did not know this --
Necco stands for New England
Confectionary Company.
And they were bought
by Spangler.
Which stands for
Southern Pennsylvania
Artisanal Nougat,
Gums, and Licorices.
So, Necco Wafers
are still available.
That delicious --
the delicious taste
of the body of candy Christ.
[ Laughter ]
Came back.
I said...
I said "anime cartoon."
I was told that's redundant.
Anime and cartoon mean
the same thing.
It would be like saying
"a nerdy anime fan."
Oh, I pronounced
"Yoseph" Goebbels,
"Joseph" Goebbels.
I apologized on behalf
of getting that wrong
to the entire Goebbels
family, and someone
wrote an interesting fact
that Joseph Goebbels
doesn't have any family left
to apologize to.
His, um...
At the end of the war...
Oof.
[ Laughter ]
That is, uh...
That is not, uh, for this.
[ Laughter ]
We had been talking about
the fairy tale
"The Elves and the Shoemaker."
You know, the classic fairy tale
where the shoemaker goes to bed
and the elves make the shoes.
We were talking about it
in reference to the fairy tale
"Shoemaker and the Elves,"
which is when the elves
who work at this show
write bad jokes,
Shoemaker shoves them
out the window.
I referred to it as a fable
and was told
it's not a fable,
it's a fairy tale.
Fables have to have a moral.
But I think if you asked any of
the elves who have written here,
they would say
the moral of the story is
steer clear of Shoemaker.
Someone also said
"You shouldn't say
'throw out the window,'
you should say 'defenestrate.'"
Defenestrate means
to throw out the window.
Which I believe,
but if anyone ever
uses it in a sentence
around you,
you have my permission to
throw them out
the [bleep] window.
[ Laughter ]
This is one of the fun things
about doing "Corrections,"
is you sometimes do some digging
on words.
Defenestrate --
I looked it up, and they say
the most famous example
of defenestration
was in 1618,
when two imperial regents
were thrown out the window
of the Prague Castle,
an event that started
the Thirty Year War.
Here's the most
fascinating thing.
Neither of the guys who were
thrown out of the window died.
They landed in a moat.
And I just feel like
if you're going to start
a 30-year war over it,
they should have died.
I just feel like -- I feel bad
for the soldier
like 17 years in who was like,
"Why are we doing this again?"
And they were like, "Iunno.
They threw Vilem and Jakub
out the window."
And he's like, "Oh, yeah,
that's a hell of a way to go."
And it's like,
"Oh, no, they didn't die."
[ Laughter ]
Interesting fact about
the Thirty Year War --
named at the beginning.
[ Laughter ]
They said -- I guess they said,
"Alright, we're going
to give this 30 years.
We obviously have
a lot of disagreements,
but if we can't sort it out
after 30 years, we all go home."
This bummed me out
because we're writing jokes,
and we wrote a joke about guys
from New Jersey
settling New Jersey,
and they were kind of
like Sopranos-y guys.
And I pitched the joke,
"Hey, look at this farmland.
Let's plant some gabagool,"
and a bunch of people here --
oh, you jackals will be thrilled
to know how many people said,
"Well, you don't plant
gabagool."
And I'm like, "I know that.
That's the joke."
And they said, "You're going
to hear it from the jackals."
And guess what --
I heard it from the jackals.
I'm a little...
I'm a little
under the weather.
I feel like now that kids
are going back to school,
they come home with colds.
But I will say that
when I am under the weather,
I have long known a sort of
homeopathic cure
from my friend Andy Samberg,
so let's see if he's there.
[ Line ringing ]
This is his homeopathic cure,
if he answers.
[ Ringing continues ]
Hey, do Robert Smith.
-♪ Boyyyys don't cryyyy ♪
-[ Laughs ] Thanks.
[ Laughter ]
That's The Cure.
Sometimes you just, you know,
you wake up on Friday morning,
you start scrolling through
the corrections on "Corrections"
and you're just gutted
by an error you made.
I've lived my entire life
thinking that David
and Richard Attenborough
were one person.
They're two different people.
David Attenborough
is the naturalist
and Richard Attenborough
is his brother,
who was in "Jurassic Park,"
"The Great Escape."
Just thought they were
the same person.
Ashamed.
Must have been
quite a sibling rivalry
between a man
who committed his life
to covering the natural world
in all its wonder
and his brother
who made a dinosaur movie.
He must've been so happy
to tell him
he was making a big-budget movie
about dinosaurs.
He's like...
[Cockney accent] "Oi, David" --
I'm assuming.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, they have fancy voices
for like, you know,
their narration
and when they do films,
but it's like,
"Oi, David, did Mum tell you
I'm doing a new film?"
He's like, "Oh, wassat, Dickie?"
He said, "Yeah, it's about a
bunch of people on an island.
Some very interesting wildlife."
And he's like," Oh, you shoulda
asked me then, Dickie.
I know quite a bit
about wildlife."
He's like, "No, I don't think
you know about this.
It's about dinosaurs."
[ Laughter ]
"Yeah, we don't want to do
a show about otters.
Newts."
[ Laughter ]
We showed a photo of Notre Dame
because the Catholic --
the joke was the Catholic Church
was going to have to
auction off the Notre Dame.
And we did a Zillow ad.
Can we show that real quick?
And a bunch of people said
that the spire collapsed.
And they're right.
I would say the spire
famously collapsed.
I feel like as far as spire --
top-three spire collapses
in the last decade?
[ Laughter ]
Some people think
we are doing this
for the full audience.
I assure you that we're not.
But, you know, more people
are coming to "Corrections."
I mean, it's all crew and staff,
but it's a hot ticket.
And people who come to
the show are gutted
that they are not
allowed to stay.
Because I think
they come on Thursday
assuming they get to stay
for "Corrections,"
which they don't,
and it was hard because some --
their disappointment
is sometimes palpable.
Like tonight,
Taylor Swift was our guest,
and she walked out
and it was just silence.
[ Laughter ]
Because they were like,
"Where's 'Corrections'?"
[ Laughter ]
This is -- I don't want to be...
[ Inhales sharply ]
I don't know.
[ Sighs ]
I don't want to,
like, tsk-tsk...
...blue humor, but someone
wrote a filthy joke.
And we kind of -- I hate to be
the police of the "Corrections"
comment section,
but it's just, we have
to be better than that.
We did a joke about
a grandfather telling his kids
how when he was younger,
he took a date to see "Ben-Hur"
and he took -- you know,
he and the date --
you know, obviously we implied.
We did not use filthy language.
We implied that they maybe,
you know, hooked up
or whatever
they called it back then.
And someone wrote --
this was their joke.
This is the first
half of the joke,
because the second half
is just too filthy.
"Was Grandpa's date annoyed
he went down on her
during 'Ben-Hur'?"
And this is not the kind
of language we use here.
And if you think I'm going to,
like, read a punch line
to a joke,
"Was Grandpa's date annoyed
he went down on her
during 'Ben-Hur'?"
I mean, in what world...
...would I share that
with the people who spend time
with me here?
I mean, shame on you.
[ Laughter ]
See me next week.